bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
en direct sur public sénat une fois de
plus l'europe est au coeur des débats
cet après midi avec cette séance de
questions cribles thématiques consacrés
au budget européen c'est le ministre
thierry repentin ministre des affaires
européennes qui est présent dans
l'hémicycle pour répondre aux questions
des sénateurs
et elles sont nombreuses hier la
commission européenne a exigé de la
france qu'elle tienne ses engagements en
matière de réduction des déficits et
qu'elle entame au plus tôt une réforme
des retraites alors tout de suite
direction l'hémicycle pour suivre ces
questions cribles bonne chance à tous
précisant que le cadre financier
pluriannuel est soumis à l'approbation
du parlement européen statuant à la
majorité des membres qui le composent le
parlement européen a donc pleinement son
mot à dire
cela m'a conduit à mettre ce sujet à
l'ordre du jour d'une réunion conjointe
des commissions des affaires européennes
de l'assemblée nationale est difficile
avec les membres européens avaient les
mêmes phrases et pardon du parlement
européen nos discussions ont en fait
ressortir un très large soutien pour ne
pas dire un soutien unanime aux demandes
du parlement européen klaus de
flexibilité pour mieux mobiliser les
crédits clause de révision à mi parcours
pour évaluer les besoins négociations
pour doter à l'avenir le budget européen
d' authentiques ressources propres
car tant que le budget européen sera
financé pour l'essentiel par des
prélèvements sur les budgets nationaux
nous aurons toujours les mêmes
difficultés pour développer les
politiques européennes
je souhaiterais savoir monsieur le
ministre quelle est la position du
gouvernement vis-à-vis de ses demandes
comment vont se dérouler les discussions
et le parlement européen et quelles sont
les perspectives d'un accord je vous
remercie
merci la réponse de monsieur le ministre
thierry repentin ministre chargé des
affaires européennes
le président de la commission des
affaires européennes vous avez rappelé
effectivement les conditions dans
lesquelles le 8 février dernier a été
négocié le cadre financier pluriannuel
dans un contexte très difficile face à
un certain nombre de gouvernements
conservateur qui ne souhaitaient pas que
l'europe soit dotée d'un vrai budget
partant sur une base de débats à 820
milliards d'euros après conviction nous
avons pu nous donner des moyens pour un
budget réorientés vers la croissance et
la solidarité puisque nous sommes
arrivés à une somme de 960 milliards
d'euros c'est maintenant une phase de
négociation qui s'ouvre avec le
parlement européen comme vous l'avez dit
nous voulons concrétiser des acquis de
ce budget avec une augmentation des
dépenses en faveur de la recherche et du
développement
une augmentation vers les mécanismes
d'interconnexion comme vous l'avez dit
en europe ou encore la pérennisation du
programme européen d' aide alimentaire
aux démunis mais aussi le travail de
lutte contre le chômage des jeunes qui
est pour nous est une priorité on
souhaite donc créer les conditions
évidemment d'un accord du parlement
vis-à-vis de cette proposition et nous
abordons positivement ces échanges que
nous avons avec cette institution pour
vous indiquer que sur les conditions en
quelque sorte posées par le parlement
européen
nous sommes favorables à une clause de
révision générale qui pourraient être
mises en oeuvre à l'horizon 2000 2017
qui permettrait de parler à la fois à ce
moment-là du volet dépenses et du volet
recettes les deux étant pour nous
intimement liées le président la
réplique par ailleurs deuxièmement a
défendu conseil européen de février une
clause de flexibilité maximale
c'est une demande du parlement européen
et troisièmement nous soutenons
pleinement la mise en place d'une
feuille de route claire précise sur
l'ensemble du système de financement de
l'union européenne y compris les
corrections rabais échec et nous vous
rejoignons en disant que nous souhaitons
que le champs explorés s'étende à
d'autres ressources que les seules tva
et taxe sur les transactions financières
que soit prévu un calendrier précis une
échéance au 1er janvier 2017 que le
conseil soit à responsabiliser sur ces
questions nous avons bon espoir que sous
la présidence irlandaise nous puissions
trouver
compte tenu des conditions des rapports
de force politiques en europe le
meilleur budget pour doter l'union
européenne d'un budget vers la
croissance et l'emploi
très bien merci monsieur fruteau
oui monsieur le ministre je le souhaite
comme vous sous la présidence irlandaise
c'est peut-être un peu optimiste mais il
faut y travailler puisque ça nous mène à
un gros moi moi moi je crois que ce qui
est positif c'est que pour la première
fois les parlements ont leur mot à dire
puisque le traité de lisbonne
elle instaure le fait que le parlement
européenne doit donner son approbation
c'est pas une codécision c'est une
approbation mais nous aussi parlements
nationaux nous profitons nous insérons
dans cette faille est plutôt dans cette
nouvelle procédure
et nous disons notre mot comme nous le
faisons aujourd'hui je crois que c'est
quelque chose de positif
moi je voudrais insister sur un des
points que vous avez développé ses les
régions en transition
il faut vraiment à tout prix que cela
soit maintenu au niveau des crédits
puisque je crois que ces trois milliards
d'euros est amplifié parce que nos
régions françaises de la tan comme on
vous l'avait indiqué ces dix régions
françaises qui n'étaient pas concernés
pour la période 2007 2013 et qui
pourront l'être pour la période 2014
je vous remercie et je vous souhaite bon
courage monsieur le ministre votre
action merci monsieur le président ce
tour la parole est à présent monsieur
eric bouquet pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen bien merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues les chiffres publiés par
eurostat en fin de semaine dernière
traduisent une dramatique augmentation
du chômage des jeunes au sein de l'union
européenne
près de 23 % des européens âgés de 15 à
24 ans sont aujourd'hui sans emploi dans
près de trois quarts des régions
d'europe
le taux de chômage des jeunes
représentent au moins le double du taux
de chômage total confronté à la
situation sociale explosive qui
représente près de 6 millions de
chômeurs de moins de 25 ans l'union
européenne a jeté en février dernier les
bases d'un dispositif destiné à lutter
contre le chômage des jeunes dans son
futur budget 2014 2020
elle prévoit ainsi une enveloppe de 6
milliards d'euros dont trois seraient
issus du fonds social européen
ces sommes
devrait permettre de financer une
garantie pour la jeunesse censé proposer
à tous les jeunes de moins de 25 ans une
offre de qualité portant sur un emploi
un complément de formation en
apprentissage ou bien un stage dans les
quatre mois suivant leur sortie de
l'enseignement ou la perte de leur
emploi
mais parallèlement à la mise en place de
ce dispositif communautaire
je constate que plusieurs états membres
passent des accords bilatéraux
c'est ainsi que l'espagne le portugal se
sont entendues ces dernières semaines
avec l'allemagne pour coopérer
étroitement dans la lutte contre le
chômage de leurs jeunes
il ya deux jours nous avons notre tour
présenté une initiative du même type en
commun avec nos voisins allemands
au cours de la présentation de ce projet
monsieur le président de la république a
insisté sur l'urgence à mobiliser très
rapidement les fonds européens prévu
monsieur le ministre je souhaiterais
donc savoir quelle est l'originalité du
dispositif que nous voulons mettre en
place avec l'allemagne si la vocation à
être étendue à l'ensemble de l'europe et
de quelle façon il il s'articulera
pardon avec les décisions qui doivent
être prises sur ce sujet lors du sommet
européen des 27 et 28 juin prochains
merci monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole monsieur le sénateur au voc est
très clairement la priorité pour
l'emploi des jeunes et la priorité
nationale et nous tentons de la faire
prendre comme une priorité également à
l'échelle de l'europe sous la présidence
sous l'impulsion de notre président les
miss français et allemands vous l'avez
dit ont pris une initiative
effectivement cette semaine michel sapin
et son homologue ou sous la forme d'art
laguiole pour discuter de ce que la
presse a indiqué être un new deal
franco-allemand de la lutte contre le
chômage des jeunes ce plan pourrait
s'articuler autour de trois points et je
veux vous les indiqué très précisément
c'est d'ailleurs dans la ligne des
propositions de la commission qui ont
été adoptées à l'occasion du paquet
emploi des jeunes de décembre 2012
il s'agit de la création d'une ligne de
crédit spéciale pour stimuler la
création d'emplois dans les petites
entreprises que pourraient mettre en
place la banque européenne
d'investissement qui a été recapitalisé
d'ailleurs de 10 milliards d'euros à la
suite de l'adoption du pacte de croiser
voulue par la france en juin 2012 c'est
ensuite la création d'une europe de
l'alternance pour stimuler effectivement
la mobilité des apprentis et pour cela
nous avons proposé d'élargir le
dispositif erasmus également aux jeunes
apprentis qui ne peuvent ils prétendre
aujourd'hui pour cela nous allons doter
la ligne de 8 2 8 milliards à 12
milliards sur la période 2014 2020 est
facilité troisièmement la création
d'entreprise par les jeunes par un accès
facilité au crédit et par les pépinières
européennes en soutien à ces initiatives
et à travers les réseaux erasmus eurest
qui seront développés il s'agit comme
vous le voyez d'outils mise en place au
niveau européen qu'il nous faut
pleinement mobilisés je souhaite aussi
vous indiquer que nous souhaitons
mobiliser le plus rapidement possible la
ligne 2 6 milliards d'euros qui a été
proposé dans le cadre financier
pluriannuel 2014-2020
et pour faire effet levier lait
concentré non pas sur un exercice de 7
ans mais les maîtres d'une façon
restreinte sur 2014 et 2015 pour
vraiment être aux côtés de la jeunesse
aujourd'hui qui attend un emploi en
europe
c'est d'ailleurs je pense un des
éléments que présent la république
française parlera ce soir à l'issue de
son entretien et qu'on aime merkel merci
monsieur bouquet si vous souhaitez
réagir aux propos du ministre
mais un jour merci monsieur ministre
cette réponse détaillée cependant
j'aurais faire part d'un certain
scepticisme face à cette multiplication
d'initiatives nationales qui semble
d'ailleurs irrité le commissaire
européen y compris à l'emploi qui
préfèreraient que soient déjà mises en
oeuvre la garantie jeunesse j'ai
tendance à penser qu'elle se prenne sous
la houlette de nos partenaires allemands
et qu'elle s'inspire trop facilement
d'un modèle d'outre-rhin dont le faible
taux de chômage des jeunes serait l'une
des grandes réussites grâce en
particulier à l'efficacité que
représenterait son système
d'apprentissage
différentes études en allemagne y
compris ont montré les limites de ce
système qui semble avoir pour grand
avantage de rapporter aux employeurs
plus qu'ils ne leur coûte et surtout de
permettre d'attirer des jeunes de pays
européens en crise je vous remercie
merci la parole à andré gattolin pour le
groupe écologiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues depuis 2008
le budget annuel de l'union européenne
et surtout les cadre financier
pluriannuel dont il découle relève du
domaine de la codécision entre le
parlement européen et le conseil
c'est une des grandes avancées du traité
de lisbonne le problème c'est que nous
nous retrouvons face à une anomalie
démocratique et cadre financier
pluriannuel sont toujours déterminés
pour une période de sept ans distingue
des mandatures du parlement qui sont
élus pour cinq ans ainsi le cadre
financier pluriannuel dans les
institutions européennes devraient
accoucher dans les semaines qui viennent
avec des difficultés qu'on connaît
fixera un cap extrêmement contraignant à
l'assemblée européenne qui sera
renouvelée elle en mai 2014 à cette
aberration de nature politique se crève
une aberration de nature économique
on peut en effet se demander s'il n'est
pas absurde vu l'évolution très rapide
de nos sociétés de nos économies de
prétendre à une planification un horizon
aussi lointain
enfin le second problème que je souhaite
soulever et celui de la fongibilité qui
semble s est établie au sein des du
budget européen entre le à l'intérieur
de certains chapitres
je pense notamment à la politique
agricole commune où on envisage une
franchise fongibilité entre la partie
des subventions agricoles qui elles sont
récurrentes et tombent automatiquement
chaque année et la partie budgétaire
consacrée au développement rural et au
verdissement de la pac
il est évident que le second mettra
beaucoup de temps à s'établir et qu' il
ya de forts de chance contenu du budget
restreint qui est votée que les
subventions agricoles prennent le dessus
et qu'on soit en mesure de financer les
changements structurels du que la
politique agricole commune mériterait
aussi monsieur ministre ma question est
double ne pensez vous pas qu'il est
temps de passer d'une logique de
programmes pluriannuels de sept à cinq
ans et qui serait élaboré pendant les
deux premières années d'une nouvelle
mandature du parlement européen
deuxièmement n'est-il pas urgent de se
doter de garde-fous à l'intérieur des
grands chapitres budgétaires de l'union
entre les dépenses récurrentes
prévisible et constante tout au long du
programme et les politiques de
transformation du modèle économique et
social européen qui renvoie à une montée
en charge plus progressive
je vous remercie merci
monsieur thierry repentin mais monsieur
le sénateur le président sutour tout à
l'heure a insisté sur le fait que le
traité de lisbonne donnait des pouvoirs
plus marquée au parlement européen nous
nous en réjouissons notamment pour
l'approbation du cadre financier
pluriannuel
nous devons garantir bien évidemment la
légitimité démocratique des grands choix
budgétaires de l'union moi je me réjouis
que le traité de lisbonne est vraiment
conforté la place en quelque sorte
institutionnelle du parlement européen
nous devons néanmoins conjuguer ces
garanties démocratiques avec la
nécessité d'une programmation
pluriannuelle de l'union européenne dans
la durée pour savoir où nous allons sur
les grandes actions de l'union
européenne et ce cadre financier il fixe
en effet de grandes orientations pour
sept ans vous l'avez rappelé cette durée
longue c'est aussi la condition de la
bonne prévisibilité des engagements et
des investissements cohérents à moyen et
long terme
c'est un des facteurs qui expliquent le
succès des grandes politiques
européennes que sont la politique de
cohésion
la pac vous l'avez cité ou encore la
politique de recherche le nouveau
parlement européen aura toutefois son
mot à dire sur les orientations de la
politique budgétaire l'union européenne
parce que d'une part il y a une
approbation
chaque automne des budgets annuels qui
se fait en codécision et que par
ailleurs grâce à la clause de révision à
mi-parcours de 2007 que la france
accepte le parlement européen aura la
possibilité s'ils le désirent en lien
avec le conseil et la commission de
revoir le contenu s'agissant de la
possibilité de réaffecter aussi des
sommes programmés dans une rubrique vers
une autre vous savez que cette
possibilité existe elle est encadrée
elle est limitée par les plafonds du
cadre financier c'est un des principaux
atouts de cette règle garantir un
respect sur une période longue des
grandes orientations politiques que
fixent le cadre et ce n'est en rien
contradictoire avec une bonne
utilisation de l'argent disponible grâce
à la flexibilité applicables aux marges
sous plafond entre année et entre
rubrique que la france accepte tous les
pays ne l'acceptent pas aujourd'hui est
en outre la mise en oeuvre de cette
flexibilité
je le rappelle à toutes et à tous dans
le cadre du budget annuel se fera
avec l'accord du parlement européen qui
sera co décideur très bien merci
monsieur gâteau leur merci monsieur le
ministre pour toutes ces précisions
je me permets comme d'insister je pense
qu' il serait plus cohérent d'avoir une
programmation à 5 ans est cohérente avec
les mandats politiques tous les pays de
l'union européenne ont abandonné la
planification il ya quelques années dans
le même dans les années 80 précisément
parce que c'était difficile de faire des
plan quinquennal alors des plans centeno
sont particulièrement compliqué enfin
sur la question de la fongibilité merci
de votre vigilance
je travaille actuellement sur un dossier
qui est le programme de soutien à la
surveillance de l'espace et je note que
la commission européenne suggère de
retirer déjà 45 millions d'euros au
programme galileo qui a un programme
pourtant éminemment stratégique pour
essayer de financer toute cette
politique de soutien à la surveillance
de l'espace donc je me dis les risques
et les volontés de la commission de
jouer la fongibilité souvent à
l'encontre de la volonté des états et
des politiques est quand même
inquiétante et il faut être très
vigilant je vous remercie
merci la parole à présent monsieur le
président jacques mézard merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues il ya effectivement deux
manières d'aborder l'accord auquel est
parvenu le conseil européen de février
2013 sur le cadre financier pluriannuel
de l'union européenne pour 2014 2020
la première c'est de se réjouir du
succès puisque après le premier échec de
novembre les 27 sont parvenus enfin à
s'entendre mais on peut aussi considérer
qu'il n'ya aucune raison de s'en réjouir
puisque cet accord prévoit pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de l'union
européenne un budget en baisse et ce qui
est très loin d'être à la hauteur des
enjeux
nous qui sommes très favorables à la
construction européenne
si nous sommes conscients des
difficultés qu'ils sont
le traverse actuellement nombre d'états
membres dans un contexte de crise
exceptionnelle
nous sommes convaincus que c'est avec un
budget européen ambitieux et non arabe
et que nous pourrons sortir de cette
crise les députés européens d'ailleurs
toutes tendances confondues ont fait
part de leur mécontentement en menaçant
de ne pas adopter le budget ils
demandent le déblocage de plus de 11
milliards d'euros dès cette année pour
faire face aux impayés de 2012 qui
menacent notamment les crédits dédiés
aux jeunes peut-être l'europe est-elle
victimes de l'austérité qu'elle a
elle-même imposée depuis plusieurs
années mais si la commission est prête à
sortir de cette logique avec des délais
supplémentaires pour les états il n'en
reste pas moins que les rabais les
autres calculs égoïstes nuiront à long
terme à l'ensemble des états européens
nous voulons nous qu'il soit donner une
véritable impulsion à l'europe comme a
commencé à le faire d'ailleurs le
président de la république avec le
retour de la croissance et de l'emploi
qui nécessite un budget européen
conséquent alors monsieur le ministre
quel progrès pouvons nous espérer sur
cette question des ressources propres
comment permettre à ce nouveau cadre
financier de réorienter la politique
européenne en faveur de la croissance et
comment dans le même temps le vrai à
l'émergence d'un gouvernement économique
européen comme le souhaite désormais la
france merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président méar je connais à
la fois l'engagement de votre groupe sur
les questions européennes et votre
attention comme élu local à la bonne
consommation des fonds européens
si je vous dis cela c'est que souvent
dans ces dossiers un peu complexe le
diable est dans le détail mais il ya
aussi quelques fois des solutions que
l'on ne perçoit pas systématiquement si
on ne fait pas effectivement une analyse
très précise moi je vais vous dire que
le mécanisme tel qu'il a été adopté du
cadre financier pluriannuel garantira
que nous serons dépenses engagées sur la
période 2014 2020 50 milliards de
dépenses supplémentaires par rapport à
la période 2007 2013 nous avons en effet
mis déclic est de consommation
qu'ils fassent que nos pays est plus
d'argent à engager sur un certain nombre
de lignes budgétaires lesquelles celles
qui sauront les plus en croissance c'est
à dire les lignes consacrées à la
croissance à l'emploi dit rubrique 1a je
vous invite de le regarder
c'est la recherche et l'innovation + 40
% d'augmentation
c'est soutenir le développement des
infrastructures plus 140 %
d'augmentation par rapport à la période
2007 2013 c'est tout ce qui concerne les
infrastructures de transport de
développement de l'énergie des télécoms
je sais que pour les territoires de
france et d'ailleurs c'est une question
importante c'est aussi l'augmentation du
programme erasmus pour tous on passera
de 8 à 12 milliards au bénéfice de la
jeunesse de l'union européenne alors
évidemment tout cela pose la question de
savoir si notre europe se dotera un jour
d'une ressource propre au delà de
l'affectation de la tva et d'une partie
je l'espère des ressources de la ttf
et bien c'est une proposition que porte
la france elle est aujourd'hui isolé
moins qu'elles ne l'étaient il ya un an
et peut-être verrons-nous dans les jours
prochains
peut-être dans les heures prochaines
certains chefs d'état ou de gouvernement
rejoindre l'ambition de la france que
l'union européenne se dote d'un budget
assise sur des ressources propres
c'est le voeu que je forme devant vous
c'est peut-être aussi en ayant quelques
informations qui laissent à penser qu'il
faut être optimiste
merci monsieur président mézard pour la
réplique
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
merci de vos propos et et merci de la
non ce que vous venez de nous faire en
confirmant très clairement à la fois la
volonté de la france d'aller vers les
ressources propres et du fait que nous
commencerions à être écoutés parce que
c'est un changement fondamental
indispensable pour l'avenir de l'europe
merci aussi d'avoir rappelé l'intérêt
que notre gros porté à l'europe est elle
le fait aussi qu élus locaux nous avions
un intérêt tout particulier à suivre le
développement des crédits européens ce
qui
or justifie notre attachement au cumul
des mandats entre autres mais au delà de
ses biens a mené merci et surtout merci
de nous avoir dit que les dépenses
engagées et je sais que vous y serez
particulièrement attentifs seront
supérieures à ce qu'elles avaient été
dans la dernière période depuis 2007
parce que c'est ça qui est important
c'est que nous puissions et en
particulier sur la recherche
l'innovation et les infrastructures
aller plus loin parce que ce c'est cela
qui montrera à nos concitoyens que
l'europe un réel avantage est qu'il est
indispensable de toujours mieux la
construire très bien la parole est à
présent monsieur jean bizet pour le
groupe ump
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
aujourd'hui à l'initiative du parlement
européen qui remplit la prennent mans le
rôle qui lui est dévolu par les traités
une vraie négociation est engagé entre
le parlement européen et le conseil sur
le budget 2013 et le cadre financier
pluriannuel 2014-2020
comme toute négociation et les longues
et difficiles mais pour la première fois
le budget repas ne se décide pas à huis
clos
c'est un bon point pour le démocratie
c'est un bon point pour la crédibilité
des institutions européennes et à ce
titre nous tenons à saluer les position
équilibrée et courageuse des eurodéputés
en particulier celui du parti
majoritaire le parti populaire européen
vous le devinez sous l'autorité de son
président joseph daul d'abord nous
souhaiterions monsieur le ministre
connaître votre calendrier optimale dans
la négociation visez-vous un accord sur
le cadre financier pluriannuel avant
l'été comme semble souhaiter la présente
la présidence irlandaise les
conséquences de la négociation du budget
européen sur la réforme de la pac seront
importantes notamment en termes de
calendrier
comment les anticipez-vous la nouvelle
pac entrera-t-elle en vigueur là aussi
en 2014
pourrait-il y avoir un accord politique
sur la réforme de la pac avant le vote
définitif du cadre financier pluriannuel
par ailleurs le gouvernement français a
déclaré que l'essentiel de la pac était
préservée or ce n'est pas tout à fait
vrai puisque l'agriculture dans son
ensemble perd 52 milliards c'est quand
même pas rien et pour la france elle
même la baisse est de 10 % et les pertes
du premier pilier ne sont pas compensés
au niveau où vous l'aviez laissé
entendre ou plus exactement le prêt de
la république lui même ennemi
d'agriculture qui on était assez
affirmatif sur le sujet la contrepartie
n'est pas de 1 milliard par an mais 2 1
milliards sur sept ans dans ces
conditions comment comptez-vous
préserver notre politique d'installation
des jeunes
comment allez-vous soutenir le
verdissement auquel nous sommes tous
favorables mais qui nécessite un
accompagnement des producteurs les
financements disponibles pour la gestion
des crises seront ils suffisants les
agriculteurs français monsieur le
ministre ont besoin de savoir les
orientations d'un échéancier et d'un
budget clair je vous remercie de votre
réponse
merci monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole en deux minutes à la fois vous
parler de négociation du budget
pluriannuel et de la pac va difficile
donc je vais aller droit à l'essentiel
la position de la france sur les
demandes exprimées par le parlement
européen pour trouver un accord fait que
nous avons bon espoir d'autant plus que
la france a accepté il y a quelques
jours
l'adoption du budget rectificatif
demandée par le parlement qui
souhaitaient en quelque sorte que nous
soyons les dépenses du passé dépense
estimée à 11 milliards 200 millions
d'euros
après vérification des comptes on est
tombé d'accord sur 7 milliards 300
millions d'euros dès cette année
ce qui veut dire d'ailleurs que la
france va apporter un chèque de 960
millions à l'union européenne c'est sa
quote-part en quelque sorte par rapport
aux dépenses du passé et qu'aujourd'hui
les discussions avec le parlement nous
permettent d'être
optimiste sur une adoption du budget de
l'union européenne sans doute à la
cession de ce mois de juillet c'est une
conviction
évidemment personne aujourd'hui ne peut
dire avec certitude que les choses se
passeront ainsi mais il ya une grande
ouverture notamment de la france pour
trouver un accord car dans le cfp il y à
des avancées qui pour nous sont
essentiels notamment la politique est
liée à l'emploi des jeunes à la lutte
contre le chômage et s'il n'y a pas
d'accord il n'y a pas ces nouveautés et
il y aura pas non plus de plan d aide
alimentaire aux plus démunis
si nous ne votons pas le budget par
ailleurs en ce qui concerne la pac je
veux vous dire monsieur bizet je vous
garantis que pour la france
le retour attendu de la pac pour les
agriculteurs français sera garanti au
niveau qu'il a été obtenu sur la période
2007 2013
simplement il y à une réaffectation
entre le 1er et le 2e pilier vous
connaissez excellemment ces choses
puisque le second pilier sera renforcée
par rapport à ce que nous obtenions par
le passé et le verdissement c'est quoi
c'est toutes les adaptations de la
politique agricole qui sont permis par
le second pilier ça veut dire quoi
la rotation des cultures les prairies
permanentes les surfaces d'intérêt
écologique comme les haies
ce sont des indications qui sont
aujourd'hui dans le règlement que nous
sommes en train de négocier en trilogue
et stéphane le foll qui négociaient
encore en début de semaine à dublin dans
une réunion informelle m'a dit que nous
étions prêts sur un accord sur la partie
agricole dès cette année pour une
application au 1er janvier 2015 les 2014
était une année de transition
merci mon cher collègue jean bizet
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie de
vos réponses
je me permettrai malgré tout sans malice
de ma part considéré que mes questions a
été clair vos réponses l'été un petit
peu moins tout simplement parce que sur
la partie budgétaire
vous allez parler effectivement de
l'impasse de l'année précédente la
période précédente de 11,2 milliards
d'euros et il n'y en a pas pour le
moment que 7,1 ou deux et qui eux ou qui
ont été entre guillemets sécurisé donc
il en manque encore quelques-uns
deuxièmement ce qui concerne la
politique agricole commune
je suis désolé le compte n'y est pas si
sur le 2e pilier
il y a eu un rattrapage à hauteur d'un
milliard 7,1 milliards comme je le
précisais sur 7 ans et non un milliard
sur je dirais chaque année donc moi je
considère si vous voulez que les
agriculteurs français ont tout lieu
d'être inquiet parce que sur la période
2014 2020 et bien l'agriculture
française ne sera pas aussi bien
accompagné par les fonds européens que
sur la période précédente
et si je dis cela c'est tout simplement
parce que l'agriculture française se
trouve ci est confrontée à une
concurrence tant en intra européen par
une augmentation de plus en plus
importante à la fois des charges et des
normes notamment des normes
environnementales
je ne dis pas que ça ne date que du
début 2012
mais c'est une agression qui commence à
devenir préoccupante et ensuite une
concurrence je dirais avec les pays
tiers
parce que ceci correspond aussi à un
manque de compétitivité par merci
monsieur les charges au niveau des
professions agricoles très bien merci la
parole à monsieur le président jean
arthuis pour le groupe u10 hussein
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le conseil
des chefs d'état et de gouvernement qui
s'est tenue les 7 et 8 février est
parvenu à un accord sur le cadre
budgétaire pluriannuel 2014-2020 âpres
discussions pour contenir l'évolution
des crédits et notamment des dépenses
administratives
la commission a dû accepter de passer sa
proposition qui était
d'un peu plus de 63 milliards à 61
milliards 600 millions et les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement ont exercé une
pression forte sur la commission pour
qu'elle réduise ses dépenses
administratives et notamment les frais
de personnel qui représentent 75% de ses
dépenses administratives pour mener à
bien cette mission délicate
la commission propose de passer la durée
du temps de travail hebdomadaire de 37
heures 30 à 40 heures sans compensation
salariale et d'élever l'âge de départ à
la retraite de 63 à 65 ans
ces mesures doivent s'engager dans les
plus brefs délais et obtenir un résultat
de réduction de 5 % des frais de
personnel d'ici 2018
eh bien monsieur le ministre je souhaite
connaître la position du gouvernement
français
je souhaite que vous nous confirmer que
le gouvernement français soutient le
passage de 37 heures 30 à 40 heures
hebdomadaires pour l'ensemble des 50000
fonctionnaire européen et l'élévation de
l'âge de départ à la retraite de 63 à 65
ans je vous remercie
merci monsieur thierry repentin sur le
président monsieur le ministre a retué
pardon vous avez effectivement raison de
dire que nous avons négocié le cfp dans
un cadre très difficile puisque nous
sommes partis sur une base ou plusieurs
pays proposait que nous discutions sur
un budget à 820 milliards d'euros après
discussion nous sommes arrivés à 960
milliards d'euros car nous considérons
que l'europe doit effectivement se doter
d'un budget qui lui permettent d'avoir
une existence en termes de relance de
l'économie concrète à l'égard des pays
qui plaident aujourd'hui une relance par
l'économie ça veut dire aussi que nous
devons négocier en quelque sorte des
efforts
pour pour tout le monde s'agissant de la
fonction publique européenne dont vous
parlez nous voulons je le dis qu'elle
soit aussi forte et de qualité parce que
ça passera aussi par cela la mise en
place de politiques structurelles qui
soit cohérente
nous nous attachons donc dans le cadre
des négociations en cours sur le statut
effectivement de la fonction publique
européenne c'est ce que nous avons
plaidé lors de la négociation du cadre
financier pluriannuel
c'est qu'il était indispensable que la
commission elle-même qui avait proposé
une hausse de plus de 10% de la rubrique
des dépenses administratives ne
s'exonère pas des efforts demandés aux
fonctions publiques nationales et que la
france rempli je crois parfaitement par
rapport à ses propres responsabilités
c'est dans ce cadre que depuis quelques
semaines s'est engagé une réforme de la
fonction publique européenne et un
accord devra aboutir en quelque sorte y
compris d'ici le vote du budget au mois
de juillet prochain
nous l'espérons en tout cas merci
monsieur le président je voudrais rendre
hommage au gouvernement pour le courage
qu'ils manifestent en proposant de
porter l'âge de départ à la retraite de
63 à 65 ans et de porter la durée du
temps de travail hebdomadaire de 37
heures 30 à 40 heures monsieur le
ministre je vous assure de notre
soutient nous à lui d y ayant dit cela
je me suis étonné des commentaires du
président de la république hier lorsque
la commission a fait connaître ses
recommandations pour permettre à la
france de respecter la trajectoire est
de permettre au déficit de refluer on de
sa de 3% du pib
eh bien monsieur le ministre je pense
que par souci de cohérence car c'est
aussi des vertus du gouvernement et
serait peut-être bon d'ouvrir des
négociations pour revoir la durée du
temps de travail hebdomadaire dans les
trois fonctions publiques et peut-être
d'être audacieux s'agissant de la
réforme des retraites et de l'âge de
départ en retraite
merci la parole est à présent madame
bernadette bourzai pour le groupe
socialiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
monsieur le ministre portera sur le
budget de la future politique agricole
commune dans le cadre du cadre financier
pluriannuel
je dirais également un mot sur la
politique de cohésion ces deux
politiques étant les plus visibles de
l'union européenne elles sont
naturellement au coeur de nos
préoccupations sur nos territoires
alors vous êtes entré le gouvernement
français comme les 27 gouvernements est
entré depuis le 13 mai dernier dans un
trilogue entre commission conseil et
parlement et parallèlement le lait le
trilogue semaine également dans le cadre
de la politique agricole commune
monsieur bizet de façon à la sable
d'ailleurs depuis plusieurs questions
cribles pose la question du montant du
budget de la pac je voudrais lui
rappeler que ayant été député européen
et membre de la commission agricole
tout le monde savait à bruxelles que le
montant de la pac de la période
2007-2013 aller décroissant et je vous
fais observer comme monsieur cazenave
l'avait fait à de nombreuses reprises
que le montant actuel qui est dévolue à
la pâques correspond exactement au
montant du budget agricole de la
dernière année c'est à dire celle de
2013 multiplié par sept
donc il fallait se préparer à cette
évolution et je pense que la france a
particulièrement bien tiré son épingle
du jeu y compris et compris en obtenant
un milliard de plus pour le
développement rural et ma question
précisément posera portera sur la
deuxième partie c'est à dire quid du
développement rural dans le cadre
stratégique pluri fonds qui sera le
nôtre
désormais et comment peut-on s'assurer
que les zones rurales pourront accéder
dans de bonnes conditions au fonds feder
au fond fse et je voudrais en concluant
demande vous demander monsieur le
ministre de bien vouloir appuyer le
fonds européen
aide aux plus démunis à qui il manque
manifestement un milliard d'euros merci
monsieur le ministre
oui même la sénatrice votre question me
permettra de réaffirmer devant vous ai
compris devant d'autres parlementaires
qui m'ont interrogé sur la question
agricole de réaffirmé que les retours
espérés pour la france au titre de la
politique agricole commune sur la
période 2014 2020 seront à la même
hauteur de ce qui a été acté sur la
période 2007 2013
plus précisément 47,6 milliards d'euros
sur la période
au titre du premier pilier et 8
milliards 800 millions d'euros au titre
du second pilier
qui est donc ce second pilier renforcer
dans la future programmation et vous
sachant défendeurs inlassable de la
montagne je pense que vous y serez
sensible car c'est des massifs aussi
qu'ils vont être plus élevé qu'il ne
l'était par le passé une bonne enveloppe
pour la pac et est à nos yeux la
condition de pouvoir modernisés réformer
cette politique de la rendre plus justes
notamment au profit des jeunes
agriculteurs des petites exploitations
de l'élevage est aussi plus verte et on
répondra à une demande y compris de la
société s'agissant du développement
rural
il s'agit effectivement aussi d'une
préoccupation à la fois pour la pac et
pour la politique de cohésion
le renforcement donc du second pilier de
la pac avec le feader va y contribuer
directement et pour la cohésion nous
sommes attachés à ce que la prochaine
programmation permettent l'action
conjointe de tous les fonds structurels
c'est à dire le feder et le fse le fonds
agricole le feader dont je viens de vous
parler m'interroge également sur la
question des régions en transition
c'est une nouveauté les régions en
transition que le gouvernement précédent
n'avait pas souhaité défendre et bien
pour ces régions en transition
c'est une intensité dead supérieur
garantie à ce qu'elles auraient touché
si nous n'avions pas créé les régions en
transition et dernier point important le
fonds d aide alimentaire aux plus
démunis
vous souhaitez qu'il soit réévaluée d'un
milliard vous auriez pu dire aussi qu'il
était supprimé
décision avait été prise en conseil
européen il y à une décision noir sur
blanc
au 31 décembre 2013 en février le
président la république française a
demandé à ce que les associations
caritatives qui oeuvrent à nos côtés sur
les territoires puissent bénéficier de
ce fonds il sera pérennisée aujourd'hui
à hauteur de 2 milliards 5 et nous
sommes ouverts à la demande du parlement
de le porter à 3 milliards 500 millions
d'euros merci madame bourzai rapidement
s'il vous plaît merci monsieur le
ministre je salue la détermination du
président de la république et du
gouvernement
la vôtre et celle de stéphane le foll
qui nous semble-t-il mène des
négociations dans le trilogue agricole
de façon tout à fait magistrale dans
l'intérêt de l'agriculture française et
de l'agriculture qui en a le plus besoin
et je souligne en particulier que la
répartition des aides de mon point de
vue doit être plus juste à l'égard des
populations qui sont dans les zones
défavorisées et à l'égard de l'élevage
merci pour le plan d' aide aux plus
démunis et je vous indique que ce matin
à la commission affaires européennes a
adopté une résolution pour faire de
l'année 2014 l'année de lutte contre le
gaspillage alimentaire
je crois qu'il s'agit en effet de
produire mais de produire pour que soit
respectée la production agricole et
qu'elles soient convenablement consommer
très bien merci la parole à présent
monsieur philippe dallier merci monsieur
le président monsieur nice mes chers
collègues comme l'a dit mon collègue
jean bizet nous nous réjouissons de
l'engagement réaliste et responsable du
parlement européen et en particulier de
nos collègues du ppe dans une
négociation budgétaire qui a été
difficile qui peut paraître complexe
mais qui conforte la démocratie
européenne dans l'esprit du traité de
lisbonne
je ne reviendrai pas sur le niveau du
budget en best alors certes moins que
cela avait été craint mais c'est bien le
résultat de la crise économique que
traverse la plupart des pays il faut
bien l'accepter mais cela ne doit pas
nous faire douter de l'avenir est plus
que jamais nous devons afficher nos
convictions européennes notre ambition
politique pour l'europe et maintenir
l'objectif d'un budget plus élevé à
terme lorsque cela sera possible
mais peut-être et surtout d'un budget
plus efficace cependant je m'interroge
quand le gouvernement évoque de manière
assez incantatoire le retour à la
croissance car je ne comprends pas bien
quelles en sont les conséquences
en matière budgétaire et pour cause le
gouvernement est-il l'avocat d'une
politique de stimulation de la dépense
au niveau européen défend t-il des
programmes qui conforterait la
croissance potentielle soutient-il des
projets transfrontaliers à forte
plus-value
il me semble qu'il serait nécessaire de
s'entendre avec nos partenaires
européens sur ces questions préalables à
toute utilisation des financements
européens
par ailleurs dans la négociation en
cours sur le budget le partage le
parlement européen a mis sur la table
des propositions concrètes et courageuse
je souhaiterais connaître la position du
gouvernement au regard de ces
propositions est tout près monsieur le
ministre a accepté une clause de
revoyure qui est une manière d'adapter
le budget européen à l'évolution de la
situation économique
êtes vous prêt à accepter plus de
flexibilité ou de fongibilité on en a
parlé dans la gestion des crédits
enfin êtes vous prêt à garantir une
gestion rigoureuse grâce par exemple à
une révision générale des politiques
publiques adaptées au niveau européen
très bien monsieur le ministre le
sénateur moi aussi je me réjouis que
nous avions adopté un budget à 960
milliards d'euros sur la période
2014-2020 bien plus élevé même si vous
estimez que c'est insuffisant à l'accord
qui avait été passé par le président de
la république nicolas sarkozy qui était
d'accord pour un budget à 860 milliards
nous avons adopté un budget de 960
milliards c'est à dire 100 milliards de
plus de ce qui était prévu par la
majorité précédente
il me semble que c'est une précision que
je devais vous dire vous dit ensuite est
ce qu'il y à des incantations en quelque
sorte sur une politique de relance de
dépenses très précisément je vais vous
dire ça se traduit comment par le fait
que nous avons en juin 2012 à l'occasion
du premier sommet européen avec le
président de la république que françois
hollande a été un pacte de relance qui
va se traduire par le fait que la banque
européenne d'investissement a été
recapitalisé de 10 milliards d'euros
avec ces 10 milliards d'euros de
recapitalisation la banque européenne
d'investissement va pouvoir prêter aux
différents et à 60 milliards de prêts
sur 2013 2014 2015 la part d'
la france sur ces 60 milliards ces 21
milliards je vous le dis aussi élu de la
république pour tous les projets
d'accompagnement sur vos territoires 7
milliards cette année 7 milliards l'an
prochain
7 milliards l'année d'après pour les
collectivités locales et nous avons
demandé à l'abbaye qu'elle prête aussi
aux petites et moyennes entreprises qui
ne trouve plus les fonds disponibles
dans les banques classiques c'est aussi
la création du lean de 6 milliards
d'euros au bénéfice de l'accompagnement
des politiques à destination de la
jeunesse j'ai déjà répondu sur cette
question tout à l'heure et que nous
allons c'est essayer de concentrer sur
l'année 2014
l année 2015 quant aux grands travaux
d'interconnexion
ils vont bénéficier d'une augmentation
budgétaire de 140%
après un arbitrage qui a entraîné tout
le monde et ses grands travaux c'est
quoi c'est par exemple canal seine nord
c'est par exemple la grande liaison
ferroviaire entre la france et l'italie
parce que derrière ces grands travaux il
y a de l'emploi non délocalisable dont
nous avons besoin pour créer des emplois
pour l'économie française et pour une
relance à l'échelle de l'europe
merci monsieur d'alliés pour une
réaction à chaud je vais faire court
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre les élections européennes
approchent l'an prochain et je crois ici
que sur tous les bancs nous sommes
inquiets du résultat qui pourrait sortir
des urnes et pas seulement en france
dans tous les pays européens on le voit
bien le sentiment anti européen
progresse et de manière très inquiétante
je pense qu'il faut que nous nous
interrogions sur le pourquoi de cette
affaire je pense qu'il faut que nous
fassions preuve de pédagogie et de
responsabilité de pédagogie pour que nos
compatriotes comprennent mieux ce à quoi
sert l'europe qu'ils comprennent
effectivement qu'elle les a beaucoup
protégé dans la crise de 2008-2009
comprendre aussi ce que vous faites du
budget ce que nous faisons du budget
européen
il faut aussi que l'administration de
bruxelles comme l'a rappelé jean arthuis
accepte de faire des économies parce que
vous avez lu la presse
il y à beaucoup de commentaires très
négatifs et beaucoup de nos concitoyens
effectivement trouve que il doit être
fait des efforts également à ce niveau
là mes chers collègues c'est ce que je
souhaite pour que le sentiment européen
puisse continuer à progresser
nouveau merci dernière question monsieur
richard ion pour le groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre et mes chers collègues ma
question au gouvernement en portera sur
le financement de la garantie pour la
jeunesse c'est une politique qui vise à
aider les états membres à proposer aux
jeunes européens un emploi une formation
un contrat d'apprentissage
un stage dans les quatre mois qui
suivent leur sortie de l'enseignement ou
la perte de l'emploi
je pense que nous tous considérons que
c'est une initiative non seulement
bienvenu mais fondamentale vous le savez
ça a été dit par monsieur bouquet nous
avons presque 25 % de chômage de jeunes
25 % 1 sur 4 6 millions de jeunes
presque 7 millions et demi si on prend
ce qui sont en périphérie 7 million et
demi de jeunes sans emploi
c'est évidemment le cancer qui ronge
notre société de l'intérieur bien le
cadre financier pluriannuel que vous
avez évoqué monsieur le ministre a prévu
six milliards d'euros entre 2014 et 2020
ça paraît beaucoup mais si on divise 6
milliards par six ans et par 7 millions
de chômeurs on arrive à quelque chose
comme 150 euros par jeune chômeur alors
le calcul est peut-être critiquer et
bien sûr mais enfin voilà ça donne ça
donne un ordre de grandeur
le président de la république propose de
mobiliser tout de suite
et selon son expression avant même que
le cas de free nanciers ne soit en place
pour 2014
une partie de ces fonds alors ma
première question c'est comment est ce
que ceux ci s'organise comment est ce
qu'on peut faire pour mobiliser une
partie de ces fonds pour cette politique
là avant que le
le budget soit soit votée la seconde
question c'est sur le financement
on a touché à la question mais je
voudrais être un peu plus précis j'ai
entendu le ministre moscovici
cette semaine dire que il pensait
rapidement sur les plus beaux shows
collet d'affecter une partie de la taxe
sur les transactions financières à à ce
financement
donc je voudrais savoir ce que ce que le
gouvernement pense de cette proposition
merci monsieur le ministre le sénateur
young le gouvernement rejoint votre
préoccupation à l'égard de l'ensemble
des dispositifs qui doivent être mises
en place pour une mobilisation de
l'ensemble des pays dans la lutte contre
le chômage qui gangrène
hélas une partie du territoire européen
je dis bien une partie car nous nous
situions sur des situations inégales
d'un pays à l'autre
certains pays de l'union européenne
aujourd'hui à un taux de chômage des
moins de 25 ans supérieure à 50%
nous n'en sommes pas là heureusement en
france néanmoins nous avons souhaité
créer pour la première fois
effectivement dans l'histoire de l'union
européenne dans le budget une somme de 6
milliards d'euros et nous souhaitons la
consommer le plus rapidement possible
comment elle sera déjà ciblé pour faire
effet masse sur les régions où le taux
de chômage des jeunes de moins de 25 ans
est la plus importante c'est à dire
supérieurs à 25%
s'agissant de la france cela permettra à
huit régions françaises de pouvoir
émerger à ces sommes disponibles et à
l'ensemble des territoires d'outre-mer
où malheureusement le chômage est plus
important nous souhaitons aussi qu'il
soit consommé dès le 1er janvier 2014
sous réserve que le budget soit adopté
d'ici là c'est pour cela que nous
souhaitons aussi pour faire masse non
pas étalé comme vous l'avez dit c'est 6
milliards sur les sept ans mais les
restreindre sur deux années 2014 et 2015
c'est la conviction de la france
il faut entraîner l'adhésion d'autres
pays et peut-être d'ailleurs qu'en fin
d'après midi
y aura-t-il d'autres pays qui
rejoindront la france sur cette ambition
il faut aussi additionner ses 6
milliards d'euros au programme erasmus
qui va être élargie de 8 à 12 milliards
en élargissant aussi le profil des
jeunes qui pourront bénéficier de cette
disposition notamment les apprentis qui
n'avaient pas droit à la mobilité aidée
financièrement par l'union européenne et
puis il y à une troisième chose c'est la
garantie jeunesse c'est à dire
l'engagement de chacun des états à faire
une proposition de formation
professionnelle d'emploi ou de stage
dans un délai de 4 mois suivant la
sortie du dispositif scolaire de jeunes
qui n'ont hélas aucune possibilité
d'intégrer un emploi
cette disposition sera mise en oeuvre en
france en septembre sous l'autorité de
michel sapin dans dix départements à
titre expérimental avant qu'ils ne
soient élargies dans les années
suivantes avec un objectif de 100 mille
jeunes merci une réaction pour quelques
secondes si vous le voulez monsieur
richard yung menacer mais je présenterai
très cursive mans je pense que c'est
effectivement là l'idée de concentrer
les moyens sur les deux premières années
du de l'exercice c'est certainement la
bonne approche et personnellement je
soutiendrai ceux ci si c'est
juridiquement réalisable ce que
j'imagine vous avez vérifié
merci mes chers collègues je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
16h pour la suite de l'examen du projet
de loi de modernisation de l'action
publique territoriale puis deux fois
pour cette séance de questions cribles
thématiques consacrées aujourd'hui au
budget européen et au cours desquelles
thierry repentin le ministre des
affaires européennes a annoncé que la
proposition de la france de voir
l'europe se doter de fonds propres de
fonds propres avait de bonnes chances
d'aboutir
tout de suite votre programme sénateurs
mission à qui s'intéressent au très haut
débit
et puis restez avec nous pour suivre la
suite des débats consacrés à la réforme
de la décentralisation à tout à l'heure